[Music]
on this monday night gridlock and
protest in ottawa
we won't give in
to those who fly racist flags as mps
resume work the disruption in the
nation's capital continues ottawa's
mayor says it's time they moved on
plus the tents blockade at an alberta
border crossing we're just simply not
ending it we're not compromising our
stand do you feel safe
no no no no anybody no no
canadian forces on the move in ukraine
we are
repositioning some of our troops
and a stunning shift in soccer
entire
power
how canada's team has become one of the
hottest in international soccer
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
[Music]
this is the nation's capital still a
parking lot of trucks and blaring horns
in front of parliament hill some of the
scenes are disturbing as for a third day
the so-called freedom convoy is
disrupting the city restricting access
for residents workers and businesses
there's anger about vaccine mandates but
also a grab bag of other grievances
hatred of the prime minister even some
nazi flags and desecration of monuments
this weekend the prime minister agrees
it is frustrating kobet is still
dominating our lives he himself tested
positive this morning and is isolating
he says he has no symptoms the right to
protest he says does not include abusing
intimidating and harassing people
freedom of expression assembly and
association are cornerstones of
democracy but nazi symbolism racist
imagery and desecration of war memorials
are not
it is an insult
to memory
and truth hate
can never
be the answer
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
most truckers like most canadians are
vaccinated and many public health
restrictions including proof of
vaccination mass mandates and capacity
limits are put in place by the provinces
not the prime minister yet the focus of
this anger is ottawa the city's mayor
says it's time for the protest to move
on abigail beeman has our top story
tonight and a warning some of the images
in it may be disturbing abigail
some people have left since saturday but
there are still hundreds of vehicles and
thousands of people here there's also a
more visible police presence monday and
the impact extends past here on
parliament hill with a school central
mall and a number of businesses closed
a weekend of this continued monday
blaring horns streets blocked by
vehicles on parliament hill and into the
downtown core many residents have not
slept for days due to the noise and
disruptions and many have been uh shut
in due to the crowds a lockdown imposed
by the protest itself we've had to call
in police
and try to have people removed from the
lobby it's gotten that aggressive but
but that's in the minority that's the
message from many truckers too who don't
condone defacing the war memorial or
flying hateful flags and say that
behavior is contained to a minority of
extremists i want to apologize to the
residents understand it's an
inconvenience and and
our horns aren't quiet right but i mean
in order to forge ahead
we're doing it peacefully we are here
lovingly and we are here for the
children the big question of course how
long will these protesters stay here if
you ask these truckers no one's really
sure although some point out vaccine
mandates mean they don't have a job to
go back to so no one's in a real rush to
leave we're not going anywhere and
we just want our lives back we want the
mandate stand and we want people to go
to work without the fear of getting
losing their job while people living in
the chaos want their lives back too the
garbage the urination defecation
uh really uh takes its toll uh how you
know has a real um
mental health effect on on people you
just feel
uneasy it's just not anything we have
ever uh witnessed protest organizers who
have raised nine million dollars on a
gofundme have not responded to interview
requests from global news and you take
the caging bulls with you one tweeted
this instructional video to help prevent
trucks from getting towed if the driver
leaves their rig ottawa's police chief
says the situation is scaling down and
so far there have been no injuries
deaths nor riots something the city's
mayor calls a remarkable achievement
ottawa police have several criminal
investigations open the chief says in
the next 24 hours they're going to be
launching a hotline to report hate
incidents suggesting that all this won't
go away anytime soon donna
abigail in ottawa thanks well members of
parliament were among those who had to
navigate their way through the
disruption and get back to doing what
they were democratically elected to do
the house of commons resumed sitting
today eric sorensen reports on how that
unfolded and the prime minister's
message to protesters
the first challenge for mps today could
they get to the office the house of
commons there was much heavier police
presence around west block mps returned
not only to get back to the people's
business but for the symbolic importance
i think it is important in the democracy
to show that we would be there folks
like this
are not going to stop me from doing my
job
but it was a nervous time for some mps
navigating through crowds that have been
raucous it's worrying to come into work
i had to walk in with my staff and i was
worried about them i was worried about
you know safety of people that are
coming to the hill to do their jobs the
prime minister was not in he now has
covet along with his two children so is
isolating i feel well
and have no symptoms but his message to
protesters in circling parliament was
blunt we are not
intimidated by those who hurl insults
and abuse there is always a right
to protest peacefully that i and others
will defend fully as part of this
democracy there is not a right
to incite violence
to perform acts of violence the
honorable leader of the opposition the
chamber where canada's political
differences are hashed out did resume
without disruption the opposition
leader's first question would the pm
meet with specific protesters namely the
truckers who want border vaccine
mandates dropped will the prime minister
move past the division and agree to meet
with some of the truckers impacted by
his federal regulations but trudeau had
made clear he would not meet with the
protesters and he will not back off
vaccine mandates the best way through
this pandemic is to get people
vaccinated that's how we end the
disruptions to our supply chains caused
by this global pandemic
one conservative mp was happy to address
demonstrators not supporting those with
extreme views but those fed up with the
restrictions i'm a supporter of of what
their message is and that's freedoms and
and the mandates anti-vax canadians and
those opposed to all mandates represent
just a small percentage of the country
in political terms the government has
seldom found itself with an issue so
one-sided an issue this liberal
government is quite comfortable debating
eric sorensen global news ottawa
[Music]
hundreds of vehicles are jamming roads
in kutz alberta a blockade at the u.s
borders into its third day protesters
are demanding an end to covet 19
restrictions including those vaccine
mandates police say they are trying to
negotiate a resolution and as heather
urex west reports patience is running
thin for those caught in the middle
they began arriving on saturday dozens
of trucks and other vehicles lining up
at southern alberta's busy canada u.s
border crossing what we'd like to see
is everything go back to the way it was
in 2019 before
all this started
all the mandates left it all the
restrictions gone and that put into
legislation so this does not happen
again over the weekend an alberta
government mla joined the protests
sharing on social media i brought the
grandkids down to the coots border today
to show them the importance of standing
up for freedom and liberty this is going
to be an issue that our caucus needs to
talk about
i think disappointed that grant hunter
made the decision to go there and
participate in that illegal blockade the
blockade must end immediately kenny said
on social media sunday before adding
operational enforcement decisions are
the responsibility of police services
rcmp say they're working to bring about
a peaceful resolution but protesters
aren't backing down it's important to
note that not every truck stuck in this
lineup is a part of the protest in fact
we spoke with a number of truckers who
are now stuck here and just want to get
home i'm stuck like a part of the 3-d
no shower nothing anything do you feel
safe no no no anybody no no safe
carrying loads of goods intended for
calgary grocery stores several truckers
tell global news they feel like hostages
caught up in a blockade that does not
represent them i'm carrying produce from
sacramento california
to calgary i cross the border on
saturday i'm over 40 hours right now
here
stuck and
just crossed the border if they have a
freedom not to vaccinate where's my
freedom i support them but i'm the one
who's stuck here who's suffering me
by monday afternoon some of the truckers
trapped in the protest were allowed to
return to calgary via a back road unable
to complete their american bound
deliveries as originally planned
rcmp say they continue to negotiate with
protest organizers to try and find a
peaceful resolution to this border
blockade but police warn that if one
cannot be found they will move in and
remove protesters by force if required
donna
all right heather yorick's west thanks
now to the crisis in ukraine prime
minister trudeau is defending his
government's decision to send non-lethal
equipment only to support the ukrainian
military
the fate of ukraine matters to the world
and to canadians i've made this very
clear including directly to president
zielinski
the prime minister took part in a debate
in the house of commons tonight about
ukraine he said there will be costs and
severe consequences if russia invades
including coordinated sanctions other
allies such as the u.s and the uk have
sent defensive weapons to ukraine today
canada's defense minister anita anand
met with her ukrainian counterpart in
ukraine and canadian military trainers
already in that country were moved away
from a volatile region crystal gomencing
reports from ukraine
canada is stepping up its efforts to
train ukrainian soldiers extending
operation unifier by three years however
trainers on the ground now near contact
lines in the donbass region are being
pulled back minister you're moving
canadian forces west of the river what
information do you have that problem to
that change
the safety and security of
the armed forces is
my top priority
at all times
and out of an abundance of caution we
are
repositioning some of our troops
it's not known if canadian officials
have new information about a potential
russian threat in eastern ukraine the
ukrainian military has battled
russian-backed separatists there since
2014.
a ceasefire is in place but is often
violated including monday when a
ukrainian soldier was killed by an
anti-tank grenade russia has threatened
to take military action at the u.n
security council russia tried
unsuccessfully to block diplomatic
dialogue fellow members of the council
and other u.n member states we urge you
to assess not only russia's statements
but their actions with clear eyes
i have clear instructions
from my government
to reiterate today
the absence of any aggressive intention
as well as ukraine's strong commitment
to peace in the russian parliament there
will be a vote in two weeks over whether
to formally recognize areas within
ukraine's borders now controlled by
pro-russian groups as independent states
more destabilization says ukraine russia
could then use these regions to build up
military assets russia's ambassador to
the u.n blasted the west for stoking
fears of war the discussions about a
threat of war is provocative in and of
itself
you
are almost calling for this you want it
to happen you're waiting for it to
happen as if you want to make your words
become a reality nato countries have
clearly stated that peace is their goal
however preparations are continuing for
a conflict those military trainers being
relocated and soon non-essential staff
at the canadian embassy will be leaving
a move the ukrainian president last week
vocally opposed saying his country is
not the titanic
donna
crystal command sing in keeve tonight
thanks
a failure of leadership in the uk
coming up what a report into lockdown
parties at number 10 says about boris
johnson
[Music]
that long-awaited report into lockdown
parties held at number 10 downing street
is out and it is not flattering to boris
johnson a senior civil servant says
there was excessive consumption of
alcohol and a lack of leadership and
today's political opponents went on the
attack
by routinely breaking the rules he set
the prime minister took us all for fools
he held people sacrificing contempt he
showed himself unfit for office
the police are still investigating and
say they've obtained more than 300
photos of potential rule breaking
redmond shannon reports on the evidence
and the political pressure on johnson
will you take responsibility prime
minister
after two months of media reports about
lockdown parties at downing street and
uk government offices it's now official
an initial civil service report
highlighting an excessive consumption of
alcohol not appropriate in a workplace
at any time it says some events should
not have been allowed to take place and
that there were failures of leadership
and judgment
a full detailed report won't be
submitted until the police finish
investigating they have plenty of
evidence to get through well over 500 of
pieces of paper about a room and a half
we received and over 300 photographs i
now come to the statement prime minister
johnson defiant told angry mps he will
make changes within his office and i'm
sorry for the things we simply didn't
get right and also sorry for the way
that this matter has been handled there
can be no doubt that the prime minister
himself is now subject to criminal
investigation
criticism two from johnson's own tory
back ventures
i gave her eulogy
and then afterwards i didn't even go to
her house for a cup of tea i drove back
three hours from kent to staffordshire
does the prime minister think i'm a fool
so either my right honourable friend had
not read the rules or didn't understand
what they meant and others around him or
they didn't think the rules applied to
number 10 which was it
johnson had been scheduled to speak with
russian president vladimir putin monday
about the crisis in ukraine that call
was reportedly cancelled so he could
deal with this crisis much closer to
home
redmond shannon global news london
but that's unusual ahead spotify tries
to fix its tune over coveted
misinformation
the pandemic has exposed a lot of
opinion masquerading as fact and a lot
of misinformation musicians like neil
young have had enough he and others have
pulled their music from spotify because
of concerns it provides a platform for
misinformation about kobit 19. that news
sent spotify shares sinking last week
they did rebound 12 today after u.s
podcaster joe rogan apologized and
promised he'd be more balanced ross lord
looks at whether that's good enough for
everyone
by his own admission joe rogan is as
surprised as anyone his show is among
the more popular podcasts in the world
we've opened the door to these new
levels of power for the government but
rogan's accommodation of guests who
suggest the pandemic is a conspiracy has
blown up in his face forcing him to
promise more accountability i will do my
best to
try to
balance out
these more controversial viewpoints
with other people's perspectives so we
can maybe find a better point of view
damage control after criticism that hit
like a hurricane rocker neil young
pulling his music from spotify because
it decided to keep hosting rogan's
podcast
in young's words spotify has become the
home of life-threatening coveted
misinformation
lies being sold for money
others including fellow canadian music
legend joni mitchell have also pulled
their songs i'm very sorry that they
feel that way i i most certainly don't
want that young and mitchell have deep
respect for vaccines both contracted
polio as children before immunization
was developed for that deadly disease
[Music]
for spotify rogan is a valued investment
under contract for 100 million dollars
u.s
the company is promising to add a
content advisory to podcast episodes
that discuss covet 19. a move this
canadian tech journalist says is
unconvincing any podcast episode that
has any discussion in and around covid19
will have this
but they don't really do anything about
the actual spread of misinformation the
backlash is still spreading quebec
artist giovino is pulling his music from
spotify to show solidarity prince harry
and meghan markle who signed deals to
produce spotify podcasts say they've
been raising concerns to the company
since last april and will keep pushing
for change
ross lord global news
next a battle of rivals canada's men's
soccer team a step closer to the world
cup
even if you're not a soccer fan it is
hard not to get caught up in the energy
of the canadian men's team they are now
a step closer to the world cup and they
got there by beating their biggest and
closest rival the united states mike
delay reports on what it took and what
comes
next for decades soccer in canada has
largely been defined by heritage italian
french greek the jerseys at patios and
bars during major tournaments have been
everything but canada's so what in the
name of world football is going on here
flags flares confetti and streamers
have canadians gone mad for soccer
getting off the bus and seeing
how crazy it was it actually feels like
we're in a football country and that it
should be noted was before the real
frenzy
a win over the u.s that made qualifying
for this year's world cup and near
certainty when not so long ago it was
only the stuff of fantasy
three years ago it seemed like a long
shot three years ago it seemed like a
long shot it's a story that is is kind
of defies logic sometimes when you think
about it when you just think about how
rapid this ascent of this team has been
the last time canada qualified for the
world cup in 1986 they played the ussr
and while the women's team capped a
generation of excellence by winning
olympic gold last year it's been
generations since the men were relevant
what changed for one manager john
herdman convinced rising stars like
alfonzo davies
who was injured and watched the game
from home that canada could be a winner
it took a bit longer for the rest of
canada to buy in but the timing couldn't
be better
people just see this team
not just providing hope for wins and
losses but they see them as just an
outlet for positivity which if we can be
honest is kind of in short supply these
days and what could be more positive
than this
mike crowley global news toronto
we all needed that that is global
national for this monday i'm donna
friesen tonight's your canada is
vancouver there are beautiful spots all
over this country please email us yours
to viewers at globalnational.com thanks
for watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow take care of yourselves bye-bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]